hey what's up guys my name is ashana
welcome back to my game engine series
and in fact welcome back to the second
day of
game engine series a week this entire
week i'm live streaming pretty much all
day every day on twitch.tv slash the
channel
we're developing this game engine series
i'm putting a lot of time into it
because i feel like we need to just
get some work done and get ahead of the
game because uh you know we've been
trailing along with all these ui changes
for a while and i want to actually get
to the point where we can make a game
with hazel so that's what's happening
this week uh definitely catch the stream
if you can and today specifically we're
going to be continuing on with the ui
stuff but
uh adding some more ui so that we can
actually basically build up scenes it's
quite an exciting episode because
we'll be making some ui so that we can
create new entities add new components
remove components and that way you
we can basically construct a scene if we
had like a blank scene in the hazelnut
editor
we'd be able to add some entities like
chuck on some components
and actually build something from
scratch which is pretty exciting last
time we
uh basically spent a lot of time
making the transform component look nice
so check out the previous episode if you
haven't already
and uh yeah without further ado let's
jump into it we'll have a quick look at
the roadmap as well
because that's kind of dictating what
we're doing so over here
on hazel engine.com roadmap there'll be
a link in the description below if
you're watching this on youtube
we have um this kind of game engine
series progression
and we're currently doing hazelnut ui
mvp we're basically finishing everything
up last episode as i mentioned transform
component ui is what we did and today
we're going to be
doing these two things so add remove
entity ui and add remove component ui so
that we can actually
add remove components and entities from
our scene and then we'll move on to uh
kind of just polishing our ui making
everything look really nice adding like
a different font so we're not using the
default time gui font
all that stuff next uh episode okay cool
so without further ado let's let's dive
in and take a look
at where we're at and what we'll be
doing so uh as i mentioned in the
previous episode as well because this is
game engine series week i'm working out
how to do
all of this stuff during the live stream
and i've already got a little patch that
i've prepared that i'll basically be
copying from
so all of this all the stuff that goes
into this episode has already been
written by me
um so more or less i should know what
i'm doing um
and i'm just going to basically uh type
it out and then explain it and then
hopefully that way it will serve as a
nice little educational resource
for you guys so basically if we think
about adding and removing entities let's
do that first
so adding and removing entities how's
that supposed to work well i like the
idea of right clicking
in inside this scene hierarchy and then
being able to create like an empty
entity
in the future when we have certain
primitives like cubes you know
cones spheres whatever it'd be nice to
be able to right click and create like a
new sphere or something
and that would essentially just be like
a empty entity with a transform
component
with like a sphere com well a sphere
component with like a mesh component
or something like that that has like a
default mesh or something on it
that's more or less what will probably
happen but at the moment like i don't
really
uh you know i don't want to create like
every possible variant of entity so like
for example
add new sprite entity or something like
that so i'll just make it so that if we
right click there'll be a little create
empty entity button that we can press
and then that will actually just add an
empty entity into the scene and then
you'll be able to select it
go down into the properties and add and
remove certain components i mean
you won't be able to remove like the
transform component which is what it
comes with but
you'll be able to like add a camera
component or add a sprite renderer
component if you wanted
to control the behavior of that specific
entity
um and then with deleting entities as
well should be pretty simple just right
click on the entity and then
select delete entity so that's the first
step of what we'll be able to do
so if we take a look at the actual
functionality before we take a look at
the ui we do have a create entity
function
pretty simple which which is great
because we can just call that and
obviously from the scene hierarchy panel
we have a context which is
our actual scene so it's really easy for
us to manipulate our scene
by adding a new entity uh what we don't
have is something called
remove entity which i'll call destroy
entity i'll zoom in
for all of you small text haters destroy
entity will basically take in
an entity and it will do exactly what it
says it will do it will just
remove it from the registry so we can
just do register
registry destroy entity
now entity at the moment we can't really
just pass it in because obviously
destroy
wants a end entity which is actually
just a un kind of id
so we could obviously add a function
that's just like you know get
you know end id or get entity id or
whatever
uh but instead of doing that what i'm
going to do uh is
over here inside sorry inside our entity
class
i'm going to add another one of these
kind of implicit conversion operators
uh it's going to be an end entity
like that right uh and it's just going
to return nc handle
so this basically lets us treat this
entity class as an energy handle because
realistically that's what it is i mean
yes it's also a scene
but it is more or less like an entity is
an
entity right so they are they should be
the same thing
uh there's should there's an easy kind
of implicit conversion and that allows
us to simply pass
in our entity class where whenever we
have a function
that takes in the entity entity right
the end entity
so that's really convenient from like a
programming point of view
and uh you can see it looks really clean
here which i obviously
like as well and i like i mean i
wouldn't abuse this for all classes but
obviously again this is our version of
entity
there should be a direct translation to
this because realistically
this entity class is just an abstraction
it's just a layer on top of this
right with some additional information
like the context but you know mostly
it's just the same as this
so it makes sense okay that's basically
all we need here right
really really simple as i mentioned now
let's go and create some of the i'm gui
ui that we need
to actually be able to add and remove
entities so the first thing i'll start
with
is just the creation code so if we go
into the scene hierarchy panel which we
do here we've got two panels here
actually
we've got the scene hierarchy and then
we've actually we've got the properties
as well maybe i'll put this up into
functions
so that it's less kind of ambiguous but
that's just the way that it currently is
so what i want to do is
maybe before we end to create a
right-click pop-up menu
and i'm gui very easy we just type in i
am gui
begin pop-up context window
right so this means that uh and we'll
have to pass in some parameters so
string id we can keep at zero which is
the default
pop-up flags as well we're not
interested in that what we do need is
this third parameter though which is
over items
basically this as far as i'm aware if we
set this to false
it won't trigger this right-click menu
if you're on an item
and an item being an entity in this case
so we have to click on a blank space
because if we click on an existing
entity
we obviously want the entity to handle
that right as in
we might want to change the context menu
that pops
up that pops up to like delete the
entity instead of add a new entity
doesn't make sense
for us to uh do that maybe in the future
like even
even if we do add like um i'm just
thinking about maybe you might want to
right click on an existing entity
and then add an entity still have ad
entity in that context menu
so that you can maybe add it as a child
entity but
regardless it's still a different
context menu because
you can't like delete an entity if you
click on a blank space
but when you click on an entity you
might want to delete it so
they do stuff to be different so this is
explicitly the menu for if you right
click
um on a blank space
so i will um i will specifically write
that in so
we'll add a menu item here create
empty entity and then
basically all we all we want to do is go
to our context which is our scene
and create an entity now i'll just call
it empty entity
um in fact i'll get rid of this because
it's pretty simple uh and then we can
just do i'm gui
uh and pop-up
that's it that's as simple as it is as
this grows
we can add separators we can add more
menu items we can add
you know menu items which with children
with child items as well so that we can
have like another list and you know
we can just grow this but for now
obviously create empty entity is all we
need
that's it i'm not even going to test
that just yet because that was
no code at all what i'm going to do
though is
[Music]
go down to where we actually render each
entity
which is draw entity node and what i
want to do here
is uh basically let's see we've got
opened
is item clicked what i want to do is
over here i want to
begin the same thing as we did here
except instead of being a window it's
going to be an item
begin pop-up context item and this is
going to let us delete the entity
so um let me just find where i did this
over here i think i called it delete
entity
so what we'll do is um this will be
begin
pop-up context item this is going to be
specifically for this tree node ex item
and then we're going to have a menu item
here called delete
entity and again this is just going to
do
m context destroy entity entity
that's it really really simple stuff now
hold your horses you might think that
this will work but it's
a little bit dodgy the reason is that
it's possible
that when we open this we still want to
do
certain other things right so once this
has been opened potentially
if we destroyed the entity here what it
means is that the rest of this code
is not going to work anymore right now
in this case i think it still will
because we're not doing anything too
dramatic i mean we are still using the
tag component this actually might be a
good idea right
so check this out if this is opened
right
we're rendering the uh as a tree node ex
we're rendering um we've got this like
specific tag that we're rendering here
right this is like an open on arrow
thing we're drawing an nc node
in the uh you know in the scene
hierarchy if it's
present essentially uh we're going to be
rendering actually no this is only if
it's open so this
might be not might not be the best
example because this is the main one
and this is if like we're rendering
children but this still stands right so
if we're rendering child nodes
the kind of uh sequence of events here
is that we we basically delete the
entire entity here and then down here
we try and access the tag from the
entity that we've destroyed
here so hopefully that makes sense as to
why that's an issue
because if we try and run this code and
we're trying to access this tag it's
not it's not going to be present anymore
we've just we've destroyed it it's gone
so because of that we actually need to
defer the destruction of this particular
entity we can't just destroy an entity
immediately
because if we did that we basically have
to like return from the function that
might not be a good thing to do because
obviously you know we have like certain
other i'm gui closing code that we may
need to run
we don't really want to do that we still
want to continue rendering this frame
but just basically mark the entity for
deletion
so that when we finished this frame
we can then delete it so next frame it's
not even going to draw this entity node
because there won't be an entity
so hopefully that makes sense so to
defer that we'll just um
we can just uh like write a little
boolean here called
entity deleted set it to false right
um and then uh set
entity deleted to true here finish
everything
and then at the very end of the function
basically
whoops if the entity was deleted we
delete it
so hopefully that kind of like uh you
know deferring the deletion of the
entity makes sense
because if we just delete it immediately
that could break
certain other things that might rely on
that entity being there so we just want
to mark it
for deletion finish the rest of our ui
rendering and then delete it at the end
so that's what this code will do so if
we run this now hopefully what should
happen is we should be able to just
create and
delete entities and hopefully uh that'll
just be the same as creating an empty
entity which is a transform component
through our staples plus code
which is what we have been doing so far
so this green square let's let's select
the red square actually right click and
then delete
oh we have an error that's good um let's
check it out uh
has component tag component and this
happens
for draw components ah
okay uh so where does draw components
get called from
selection context okay that's the other
thing we actually need to do if we
delete
um an entity that entity was currently
selected and our properties panel
is supposed to um obviously display the
properties for the currently selected
entity
now this selection context which is the
current entity that we've selected and
then deleted
doesn't doesn't exist anymore right so
they we can't retrieve
um we can't retrieve any properties from
the selection context because this
entity has been deleted
so what we need to do is basically clear
the selection context so if we come
over here and i'm glad this came up
because i forgot to copy down that
that bit of code um but this way i think
it makes a little bit more sense
so if the entity was deleted not only
did we destroy the entity but
if the selection context we can do a
little check here if the selection
context is actually
the entity that we've just deleted right
then we can actually clear the selection
context so we don't really want to touch
it if it's not even selected obviously
we don't want to like have another
entity selected and then we delete
something else and it clears our
selection context
but if it is this entity then we do have
to clear it because otherwise we're not
going to be able to retrieve any of the
other things
from there um
okay cool so right click on the red
square delete empty
there you go it's gone we should also be
able to create an empty entity if we
right click somewhere here and obviously
if we right click on an existing entity
we'll get deleted so create empty entity
there it is we have an empty entity we
can call it something else
something else didn't we have the wasd
only work if it was focused
why is that just working now oh that's
part of the script sorry not the camera
never mind
that's expected for now um okay so
there's something else and then we can
delete something else and we can delete
the green square
anyway point is everything works and
looks good so now what i want to be able
to do is add components right
so it's good that we can add entities
and stuff like that but we also need to
be able to create components and remove
components
now again like some of the ui here you
could spend quite a while
uh on so i don't really want to spend
too much time on that but let's first of
all add the add component
functionality so we are focusing on
functionality we will we'll focus on
polish
in the next episode when we get there so
when we draw these components
if we have a selection context
is our properties panel i'm just going
to create a button underneath all of our
components so we've drawn all of our
components now we're kind of underneath
i'm just going to create a button that's
going to be called
um add component
whoops uh button add components
and what this is going to do is actually
open a pop-up menu so this is kind of
like opening a context menu for
right-click but this is actually we'll
press a button to open it
and this is going to be now we have to
provide it with a string id it doesn't
matter what this is just make sure that
it's like a unique identifier
and then we can uh begin the pop-up
so basically what this will do is and we
use that id again
so basically what this will do is if we
click on the button
it will open this pop-up which will then
basically render the pop-up right until
it's closed
and this pop-up will contain a list of
buttons
essentially you could probably i'm not
sure if menu items
would work here i guess they would work
here maybe we should try menu items i
don't know i wrote buttons but let's
just see what a menu item looks like
um because yeah we'll just decide what
looks better i guess
so let's just say camera right so if we
click on this we should be adding
a camera component to the selection
context so add components
camera components
um and then we'll close
uh is there an end menu item i don't
think so no there shouldn't be
um but we do have to close the pop-up
because obviously we don't want to leave
that pop-up menu open once we've
actually um
once we've actually added a component so
that's the camera and then we'll do the
same thing for this bright renderer
so i'm calling it sprite renderer and
that's going to add the sprite render
component
to the current selection context and
then end the pop-up that's it
really really simple nothing to it
really now you can probably notice
that first of all we are going to have a
lot of components in the future
and this code is fairly uh like simple
right i mean really the only variables
here are the string which is the name
and then the actual like component so we
could easily
um you know bring this out into like a
templated function or
even have some kind of component
registry
so that we can iterate over every
component over every component inside
hazel like in a for loop or something
and then draw them here
that might be useful for like more of a
plug-in system because if someone adds
their own custom component
we obviously want to show up here and if
there's no registry then there's no way
to really do that without modifying this
code
so we'll talk about um maybe making that
a little bit more flexible in the future
but for now
we will leave it as is so you can see
with this add component button so let's
let's try this out let's create a new
empty entity i'll make a pink square
i'll call it pink square i'll add the
component sprite renderer
and then you can see we've got a white
square now we can change it to pink
and obviously move it out of the way
because it's in front of the red square
there you go right and then i can scale
it up do whatever i want with it
and that's obviously a new entity that
i've added now i can right click and hit
delete and that works
as well now finally i want to be able to
remove a component
so how do i do this well um
the way basically what me and the stream
came up with
uh is kind of similar to what unity has
it's got like a little
triple dot system going on on the right
of the header
for the component so as i as i try
desperately to find
this code draw components what i want to
do basically
and not every component is removable
like this one is
sorry this one isn't transform component
we don't want to be able to remove that
but camera component is obviously
removable how do we do that well
let's take a look at that so first of
all we need to adjust our tree node
flags a little bit and obviously the
all of the tree nodes here are going to
have the same flags so i'm actually
going to just
um bring this out here and just write
const i am going
three note flags tree node
flags equals that for now there's a few
other things that i want
um i want it and this is more of like us
we won't do any styling
styling stuff just just yet we'll do i
am gooey tree node flags
allow item overlap though because i
think that that's going to be required
for what we're about to do
uh and then i'll replace all of the tree
of all of the trainer exes should now
have
tree note flags so that's going in here
tree node flags
all right cool um so now what we'll do
is uh the reason i did this is because
i'm actually going to add a button
that's on the same kind of
uh line i guess as the actual header for
this kind of
trino drop down which is our kind of
component header
so um the way the way that we're going
to do that
is uh we need to basically change this
so that we uh render it separately
because in between these two we need to
render our button
and if i just do i'm going same line
and then i'll throw in our button
which i'll just make a plus sign at this
point because it'll show our extra stuff
uh then over here i'm going to open a
pop-up
called component settings
and this component settings again this
is just an id it's not not a label that
will be rendered
uh we'll open uh like component settings
um we will where should we begin that
pop-up
uh i guess we can probably begin it
immediately
so we'll just do if i'm going
uh begin pop-up
component settings and
pop-up so this is going to
contain our menu item for removing a
component so i'm going to remove
component uh sorry
i'm gui uh menu item
remove component again
it's going to set remove component to
true so we're deferring
removing this
and that's all it's going to do and then
a little bit later on
if like once we render all this stuff
because obviously this relies on the
current component this is for the
transform components this is probably a
bad
place to do it we'll move it in a minute
but if
a remove component is true then we
basically just do entity
remove component and that's it and in
this case it's the transform component
but we obviously can't remove the
transform but you get the point it's
just this right
so what we're going to do is take this
uh
uh this whole i'm going same line this
button code we're gonna take it and
let's make our sprite renderer component
the one that we're gonna experiment on
so this obviously we need to bring out
into here
like that um and then we'll do same line
we'll have the button
and then we'll we'll do this here the
reason is i want to tweak this code to
make it good
first and then we'll copy paste it
everywhere else now as i say the words
copy and paste you might be thinking why
is there so much copying and pasting
there shouldn't be right we're going to
refactor all of these components out
into a function so that all of the stuff
that is common across
every component stays that way so that
we don't have to like copy and paste
this code all the time because obviously
it's
a bit of a drag and it's going to lead
to some bugs potentially in the future
or at the very least
possible inconsistencies okay so
now that we have this right it's going
to look terrible but it should work
and that's kind of the goal
okay so we should be able so we have
this little plus sign you can see it
does look terrible
next to sprite render and we'll talk
about improving it a little bit actually
in this episode
but uh we should be able to remove the
sprite renderer so for the red square we
can right click on this oh sorry not
right click just click on this
and then remove component you can see
it's gone and we now
no longer have our red square same with
green square let's remove that component
it's gone okay
really simple stuff now how can we make
this look a little bit better we're not
going to spend too much time on that
today
because i do want to improve the styling
in the next episode
but basically um what i'm going to do is
uh and what i did um during the live
streams was
instead of this kind of uh um
instead of aligning this left i want to
align it to the right so what i'll do is
i'll get the current window width
and you can just uh type this into it as
a parameter into the same line
this is the same line function we'll
subtract 25
um and then i'll actually make the
button have a particular size
so i think 20 by 20 is what we had it as
okay uh and whoops this is obviously
something that goes into here
okay so that should look quite a bit
better on the final thing was before we
even open this thing
uh i also had i also pushed and this is
more like a
stylish thing i guess a style thing um
but basically i uh set the frame padding
to be 4 4 which just kind of made it
look a little bit better and then we can
pop it after i guess the button
so we're going a little bit into the
next episode with this kind of styles
and styling everything but i think that
it will look a little bit nicer now
which could be nice
okay so um there we go we've got sprite
renderer it appears on this side
this is still looking a bit thin again
it won't because we'll play around with
it and make it look a bit better
but you should be able to see now that
we have the button on the right side
over here we'll also make it so that the
so these things have a frame in the next
episode
but ultimately you can click here and
click on remove component and it works
okay
so uh in summary let's test this out
because we should be able to now
basically create a blank scene and just
build it
build up our current scene just using
what we've got here so let's delete
everything i'll delete all the cameras
um there's actually this brings me back
to a little camera bug that we have but
we'll
deal with that in a minute so if i
create an empty entity uh let's
let's just make this our camera i won't
add the camera component yet i'll make
another empty entity this will be our
square
[Applause]
i'll add a sprite renderer component to
our square and make it pink
uh and then obviously we need to add the
camera so we see something
you can see that well we don't see
anything right we should until we resize
and then we suddenly see it the reason
is that uh if you notice what happens
with uh the camera when we have a scene
camera
we have a function called recalculate
projection that is based on the viewport
size so we basically need to set the
viewport size if we don't do this then
it doesn't work
now i think that the reason this worked
before was because um
set viewport size runs on viewport
resize
right so on viewport fly flying around
on viewport resize inside the same class
go away on viewport resize inside the
same class
[Music]
you can see tries to get all the camera
components and actually runs the set
viewport size function on all of them
now on viewport resize is called on the
very first frame because if we check out
this frame buffer specification we know
the v plus size is not set at the moment
we get the current size and then we
call viewport resize so because this
happens on the first frame of our actual
rendering
it works like for when we start the
application because obviously we set up
the camera
before the first frame uh that doesn't
work anymore so what we actually need to
do here
and there's a few solutions to this but
ultimately when we add a camera
component
we probably want to trigger a resize now
we don't want to trigger a resize over
all of the cameras in the scene but just
that specific camera that we've now
added
we need to basically make sure that it
adheres to the current viewport
if that's what it wants if it's not
rendering like offscreen to something
else potentially
so how do we do that well we basically
we can't do that from within the camera
class because we need the viewport size
and where is the viewport size
technically it's inside the same class
right we have viewport width and height
so the scene class has to be aware of a
camera component being added
now and actually has a mechanism set up
for this
what you can do is you can do something
like registry uh
is it uh on construct and then on so if
we construct a camera component we can
do dot connect
and then add an actual function like you
can put a little like function
into here it's not going to be a member
function or anything like that
this complicates things a little bit
because it's fine if
you just want to interact with the
registry itself but if you want to
interact with the context which is a
scene
you need some kind of like global way
potentially of getting a list of scenes
which we will technically have in the
future because we'll need that
but we don't want to have it at this
stage so what i kind of did instead
is basically i just had a new i added a
new function to the entity class
and this isn't really in the entity
class but it's more so what happens is
when you add a component
what it will actually do is uh so we'll
have our component that we add here
is there'll be a uh callback into the
scene to handle
a particular event that might happen if
we actually add that component
so essentially what this will be is
mseen
on component added t
right so this means that we've added a
component to the cena specifically to a
particular entity which of course
is well just this in this case right
and then that way we can handle it now
we could also pass the component along
that's something that we could do if we
really wanted to that way we wouldn't
need to retrieve it from the entity
um so we've added this component to the
empty i mean i guess i'll probably leave
it like that i didn't do that during the
live stream but i will here
and then what we'll do is uh this will
this will be a private function
inside the scene class we are friends
with the scene
so if you look at this we are friend
class entity here
which means that we can access all the
private members um and then i'm going to
add a template type name t that'll be
the component obviously
void on component added entity
entity and then the component
now i'm not going to implement this here
right i'm going to use a little bit of a
trick that not many people know about
but basically what i want to do is
create a bunch of template
specializations for this that are inside
the cpp file
the reason is i don't want to implement
all of them in the header file it's
going to make it really messy
what i'm going to do instead and i'm not
100 sure if this is in the simple class
standard or if it works across all
compilers so please correct me if i'm
wrong
but what i'm going to do is take this
template and implement it inside the cpp
file
so this default template will just
static assert
right because you're never supposed to
not have a specialization for it
and then what i'll do um and sorry this
would be a
scene on component added
and then what i'm going to do is write a
template specialization here
so avoid seeing our component added so
this will be like for example for the
transform component
nc entity transform
component and that will do something now
the transform component doesn't need to
do anything
uh so we'll leave it blank unless we
want to obviously do something in the
future but we basically have to have one
of these
for each component because if we don't
then uh when we try and add to the
entity it's not going to work
uh because uh it's going to try and call
on component added and it's basically
going to give us a linking error
because there's no overload for it and
since we've implemented the
uh template in the sql source file that
needs to be present
so that's kind of my little solution for
now um
the only way the only reason why i'm
slightly concerned about this is because
it
really might not work for when we have
custom components and stuff like that
but you know there are other ways around
it like at the moment we are
relying on templates but we could
definitely have some kind of
you know we are we know what component
we're adding so we could have like a get
component id function on each component
maybe
and then that could like you know do
scene on component added without a
template right because it's got the
actual id of whatever
uh class you know we're trying to add
and maybe every component needs to have
like a get id function i don't know
there's so many ways you could kind of
do this
um but for now we'll just do it this way
especially because we don't have any
components i might revisit this next
time
um so this though will do the right
thing it'll just do component which is a
camera component
dot camera dot set viewport size and
guess what we can just use viewport
width and viewport height
so now we're setting those correctly and
that's all we need to do but we also
need one of these
for every other component so sprite
renderer tag and native script component
is what i've got here
sprite renderer component
tag component probably should do this in
order
um and then uh native
script component
okay that's done that should work um
and now we have a way to handle all
these components being added which is
kind of nice as well
uh let's try and run that that should
work if we get any linking errors it's
probably because we've forgotten
a specialization but i think we should
be okay
uh okay so now uh if
i do what i did last time so i'll delete
everything
including the cameras i'll create my
pink square add component sprite
renderer let's make it pink for fun
and then i'll create a new empty entity
which will be our camera and i should
just be able to do add component camera
and you can see our pink square
immediately
okay that's how that works now obviously
uh
like you probably wouldn't even need to
do this in the future because
this is kind of even though this is like
the editor view it's actually kind of
like the runtime
at the moment right so this camera
entity is obviously supposed to be used
in the runtime when we actually like
run the game this camera is what renders
when we're not running the game we
should have some kind of editor camera
that's you know present regardless of
whether or not we actually have a camera
entity in our scene or not
so that's not really like correct i
guess
but obviously for now we are actually
mandating you to have a camera inside
your scene
if you want to see something so that's
how that works
hopefully uh all this made sense uh next
episode we're going to spend some time
making everything look
a whole lot prettier um and i'm really
looking forward to doing that we'll add
a new font and stuff like that
and just generally make everything look
good and spend some time on that thank
you all for watching don't forget you
can help support
this series by going to patreon.com
where you get access to previous live
streams as well as like
the hazel dev code which is way more
advanced than this
i will see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you